hello everybody my name is Nia and I'm
the black female engineer and I'm also a
girly girl I love makeup I love fashion
I love dressing up I love colors and
Sparkle and all of that and if you're a
fellow girly girl you may think that
Tech isn't for you or that Tech doesn't
want you and I hope that through this
video I teach you something completely
opposite and I may encourage you to
maybe I don't know maybe do the thing
that maybe you've been thinking about if
you've been pondering code or pondering
Tech or what that life would be like I'm
going to do my makeup during this
conversation and so let's go and get un
ready okay I'm going start out with some
sunscreen as yall should always do quick
warning the sunscreen I have is one of
super groups sunscreens but it doesn't
really blend well to my skin tone so
you're going to see a white cast on me
after applying that so please bear with
me this
is yeah it's the the glow screen SPF
40 and I'm really shocked that it
doesn't blend well to my skin tone
because it starts off with like a
tannish pigment but it said this is the
pigment you will end
with I've Loved makeup since I was a kid
like I remember the first time I tried
makeup on was probably when I was like 7
or eight but it wasn't until I was 13
that I was fully allowed to start
exploring with makeup like many black
women mother was Jackie AA and so I
really appreciate her and people like
Patricia brigh and even just yeah maybe
non people of color
women who just helped
me perfect my makeup game I really
appreciate it but this love for makeup
is something that is very much often
attributed to girly girls love for
makeup love for
style Aesthetics things like that and I
don't mind it at all what I do mind is
then this notion of oh you're a girly
girl and so therefore you probably
aren't good at X you probably aren't
interested in why things like
that one thing that helps me because
stereotypes are often just infuriating
and not fun to deal with but one thing
that does help me is thinking about like
okay why did this stereotype come to be
and I thought about this with stem and
with girly girls who still love to code
and want to be part of tech very much or
don't even know that they want to be
part of tech cuz they've never even
considered it because of the Box other
people have put them in and I was like
you know what
there was a solid amount of time in
America at the very least but in many
parts of the world where women weren't
granted the opportunity for Education
the norm was men get an education and
they provide and women are the
homekeepers and raise children and
things like that and then when women
were provided the opport unity and the
legal right to an
education that switched things up it
allowed women to yes get more education
but at the same time there are also more
opportunities for getting your own money
as a woman and being more independent as
a woman and really moving away from a
man needing to provide you all of those
things and the reason this is important
is
because that means that at a certain
time a woman seeking an
education was a woman doing the thing
that the men did a woman
seeking to learn and to work and things
like that was going against
their pre
provided Notions of what a woman
is and so now fast forward to
2023 and we have terms like girly girl
and things like that and those TP of
terms in my opinion aren't like
inherently
bad where it gets bad is saying that I
can't do some but like we'll get back to
that but to be a girly girl on its like
face means to be really really um to be
really really deep rooted in Womanhood
or girlhood and there was a solid amount
of time there where girlhood meant not
getting an education girlhood meant not
working and making your own money and
so I'm not saying it's right but like I
said knowing where certain stereotypes
come from it does help me because it
helps me remove myself from saying okay
so so Ando person is just an it
removes myself from saying it's like no
it's not necess say that so and so is
simply just anole but the world in
general this is what's happening and
like what has been
granted is the newer model but here's
the thing it's
2023 and so if your 32-year-old jack
over there saying oh that's weird that
you want to be in Tech because you're
such a girly girl
like no there's it's 2023 my guy like
what the hell but I do want to I did
want to provide that
initial thought process I had that being
said screw that it's 2023 and
um you can be a girly girl and like Tech
you can be a girly girl and want to work
full-time and want to be in you know the
gaming industry and things like that
like
I again it's Str tr3 I'm pretty sure
many people know this but for some
reason it's one of those things that
even if people know it
conceptually it's not
necessarily practiced enough still for
people to have to face it head on men
haven't really had to face it even
though they know conceptually what is
allowed in the society and what's
encouraged in the
society they've never had to face it and
so when it's time to face it that's when
being being loose with the tongue occurs
and that's where the truth really comes
out about what they really think about
certain things you
know so ladies how do we have men and
people cuz there are also plenty of
other people who aren't men that
constantly say things that makes one
thing like oh are you saying that girly
girls can't do this or that so it's not
just men I'm not trying to make this
like a man versus woman thing because
it's definitely not just men but ladies
girly girls how do we help our fellow
mates who think such things
well you got to you got to make it not
weird anymore how do you do this well
step one is is learn to code now I'm
going to go over a whole girly girls
guide to Tech some of these notes I have
some of these steps I have will be
specific to girly girls but some will
not be one of the very first things that
will not be is that advice of learn to
code whether you're a girly girl or not
you got to learn to code you got to
learn some of the most popular languages
is being used in Tech today this looks
harsh now give it a moment okay you got
to trust the process I like
to sculpt out where the natural Shadows
of my face are so like I have a natural
you can't really see it now but I have a
natural dark um like indent right here
like a natural contour and so I like to
Contour just above it and then sculpt it
through like the this way because when
you see my face without makeup and maybe
you guys saw it naturally that's how my
face and the like dark um Contours of my
face go especially when the lights
hitting it and things like that so I
like to add that with the Contour
stick see so that's the side now let's
Bend
out this
side and you know what the gag is with
all of this with the notion of like oh
girly girls can't possibly be as good or
better at Tech or in code than other
people the gag is there are so many
traits that girly girls do have that
would actually make them a phenomenal
developer for
example girly girls are often extremely
detail oriented you see me with my
beauty blender you see me going over
every
specific spot on my face that I want to
pay attention to you see the time I'm
putting to everything because I care
about each specific detail girly girls
are often extremely detail oriented and
it can be honestly the trait that makes
or breaks
a coder or a future cater this ability
to look at things so granularly and
solve problems and just understand the
need for such attention for the
bigger concept for the bigger picture we
talking about stereotypes and things
like that over the
years girly girls and like girls in
general have been made fun of for being
sensitive or crying and things like that
but I think many of us have been able to
see like now that's like no that's not
really something to make fun of in a
place where we're caring about the user
experience that matters being able to be
empathetic with a user's experience
really really matters in the tech
World a person a developer being able to
put themselves into an end user shoes is
a skill that saves millions of dollars
the amount of tech tragedies that could
have been avoided if some somebody was
just thinking about the end user first
it's it's absurd and so no don't think
that me or other people when we say like
no girly girls could be actually are are
and could be phenomenal developers
that's not just something to be taken
lightly like that's something that I'm
fully saying with my chest because of
all of these traits that exist within
girly girls you
know
even something that seems more maybe
like Vain and I'm I'm going to use words
that other people have used because I
really am trying to drive the point home
something more vain like
Aesthetics matters when you are building
code and apps and platforms for millions
of people to see they're going to care
how pretty or not pretty this looks you
know some of the best languages that I
recommend exploring if you are looking
to get into code in general are
JavaScript python Swift and SQL those
are really really great popular
languages that are also not as difficult
to learn as some other languages like
maybe Java or C++ I started out in tech
only knowing two languages JavaScript
and Ruby however I was able to get a job
with a company that used primarily
python because by me knowing the general
language of JavaScript it put me in a
place where it's like oh no like you are
obviously a fast learner and you'll be
able to learn this other language
quickly because in terms of rules and
things like that they follow the same
types of rules maybe they speak it in a
different way having a let's say comma
instead of a
semicolon but yeah you don't need to
learn every language Under the Sun pick
one and know it well because there are
hundreds of companies that use that
language whether it be JavaScript
whether it be python whether it be swift
which is the language used for mobile
development for Apple
development or SQL which is great for
people who are more data inclined which
if you are a girly girl and you're super
detail or oriented and you like to see
cause and effect of things then you
actually might really like a career in
data analysis so SQ would be a fantastic
language to
learn I'm going need to do this in quiet
because I will mess up so one moment
I've never been good at doing my
eyebrows I honestly didn't even pay
attention to them until like a couple
years
[Music]
ago now to go
into how best to learn these languages
this specific tip is based
on a girly girl and that is to use code
academy
I've used code academy a lot over the
years they are a fantastic tool because
they really break things up into bite
size just non overwhelming
pieces code academy is cute code academy
they did a good job with it they have a
really fun cute clean user interface
while still when you're coding when
you're using their um lessons you still
obviously are getting a lot out of it
and
it's making an impact on your learning
but it's also like oh wow this is cute
it's I don't know hard things are more
fun when they're cute I might have done
something there I might write that down
and put it on a shirt I like that I know
there's a boy out there watching this
that is seeing me say this and it's like
I know that's the truth and I'm like be
quiet okay let me blend this side SL out
more cool let's set this
bch look up while applying concealer and
setting the under
eye up up up up I'm going blend it more
don't worry okay awesome you know what
languages to learn you know what tool to
use for your girly girl aesthetic and
Vibe now what do we do afterwards we got
the knowledge use the right tools now
what third step is to practice with
projects this is a step I recommend
always especially if you
are not a new person on my channel you
know I really really say this a lot but
I always say let your hobbies and your
natural interests direct what projects
you
do here's an
example I was in a coding boot camp
from Summer 2020 June 2020 to October
2020 one of the projects I did was
called Rouge it was a makeup web app
that would recommend
certain products
based on if you wanted a nighttime or
daytime look but let me say this real
quick though when I say build projects
I'm not saying build projects for other
people like the public to see no this
project and many of my other projects
were never intended to be seen by the
public or used by the public it simply
is what you do to make sure that certain
Tech and coding Concepts stick for you
and also show it to an eventual employer
that's certain Concepts you understand
and can do if you decid to put that
project onto your portfolio that you
then showed
employers I like to go back in to my
under eye after I've set my entire
face with just a tiny bit of
powder especially since it's winter I'm
not going to use too
much and I don't really blend in too
much because I want to like kind of
naturally seep into my
skin and then after I'm done doing my ey
Shadow I'll see what's left over and
blend okay see super super subtle you
can see kind of the harsh line right
here and so after I do my ey Shadow I'll
go back okay back to Rouge in Rouge what
what you would do as a
user is you would get
onto the app was a web app built with uh
JavaScript react Ruby and Ruby un
rails react is a framework for
JavaScript Ruby on Rails is a framework
is a framework for Ruby and framework
really just means the calculator version
where there's long division and there's
a calculator so JavaScript and Ruby are
the long division long multiplication
and then the framework is the calculator
so it really just allows for faster uh
development if you know how to use it
the right way obviously so user would
get on to Rouge and see a large amount
of makeup products and they would say I
want a daytime look by clicking I
believe it was like a button that said
daytime or nighttime so You' click
daytime or You' click night night time
and then those products would
filter and I know this looks I know this
looks wild give me a second trust the
process sorry I didn't mean to yell um
yes those products would then filter
accordingly when you saw that like let's
say there was an eyes
Shadow let's say there was an ey Shadow
you liked you'd click on the eyes Shadow
and it would tell you all different
information about the shadow it tell you
the brand the color
the description and where to buy it and
then if you wanted to buy it then you
can click buy and it would take you to
that Brand's uh page you could create a
whole like shopping cart within the web
app of the products you liked most oo
there's something in my eye something
it's Shadow it's definitely Shadow
ah okay if I start crying
just move
along oh my gosh it's
a red red eyeballs are not what I was
going for with this makeup look so I'm
hoping it resolves itself so I don't
like this okay oh my
goodness
ow and so there's a really simple
example of a project I
did
that I was led to simply because I
wanted to do a project based off of my
interest and makeup is a huge part part
of my interest people really really
liked this project too like don't think
that like because it's makeup or
something that people won't be
interested no people really did like
this project they thought it was really
unique and fun and from a conceptual
Point really um whatchacallit really
like useful because do you remember like
10 years ago scrolling through scrolling
flipping through a magazine and saying
like how to get from daytime to night
time in like 10 minutes and I remember
seeing this video on like Tik Tok that
was like man when I grew up I really
thought getting from daytime to night
time was a much bigger problem than it
was it was much more stressful of an
issue because that was seriously a
column in every single magazine I would
read as a kid and so with that in mind I
was like yeah let me do a daytime to
nighttime type web app you know and so
leaning into projects that showcase your
girly girlness that showcase your love
for fashion and makeup and shoes and
Aesthetics and like just and glitter you
know what I mean
showcase who you are through those
projects because that's one of the ways
you can easily show people hey I am a
self-proclaimed girly girl and this is
why that's so awesome because look at
what I just
made I haven't found a lip liner I
really really liked yet I have tried so
many different lip liners but I really
really like Urban
decay's um eyeshadow heat if yall saw
that's actually what I was using on my
eyebrows as well but for my lips I like
to line my lips with the N Fuego it's
this like there's I've hit metal I've
hit metal okay so don't judge but it's
this one right here that I like to use
for my lips as a liner and then this is
the one that I use for my
brows
so I I'll talk so
much I like to go in with my favorite
lip gloss fenty's heat in hot
chocolate yeah hot chocolate lit with an
eye it's funny I recently had an evening
with some of my girlfriends where we
made cocktails to that represented like
the friend we were assigned to so I was
assigned to a different friend and a
different friend was assigned to me and
we showed up with cocktails that showed
that person's personality and the person
who was assigned to me she made her
drinks like this really pretty Plum
color cuz she was like I love how like
you always do your lips that color is
very like you that's what I think about
when I think of you and I love it so
much and so I this was like two nights
ago so I'm thinking about it right now
while putting this
on I thought that was very
sweet okay now let me put on my lashes
for some reason I always like I think
it's cuz I don't want to put the ey
Shadow brush
away so before I put the ey Shadow brush
away I always go to my lips and then
when I'm done with my lips I go back to
my eyes and finish off with
mascara I don't have the longest lashes
it's something that I will just have
to make terms with in this
life
okay so that's this
eye some other examples of projects that
you could do as a girly
girl one could be an outfit maker let's
say a person puts in um needs to take
pictures of the different articles of
clothing that they have and they label
as pants shirt Etc then create an app
that randomizes on a very simple like uh
mindset randomizes their different
shirts and randomizes their different
pants and their different shoes and then
boom there's an outfit for them to make
it a little bit more complex you can ask
for things like oh like would you make
would you consider this a casual shirt a
more elevated shirt would you consider
this a more loud skirt or not that could
be also be something you put into
consideration with that randomization
feature and so make three to five
projects like that portfolio ready
projects like that and definitely you
can start off by making them more basic
levels so it's not ready for portfolio
yet but once you get more and more
comfortable and also know when I'm
talking about projects and whatnot I'm
not saying you finished learning and now
you're onto projects no you simply
learned enough to start tinkering around
on your own and building projects and
then whenever you come across something
you want to add but you don't know how
to add then go back to learning and go
back to looking up YouTube videos of how
to add things and why that works and
things like that and it's honestly a
very big iteration process between
building projects and learning just over
and over and over again until you get to
that project you want to add to a
portfolio and so after you have your
portfolio all good and ready it is time
to start job hunting fun fun I mean it's
fun because it's probably why you were
doing this in the first place and so to
finally be at that stage is really
awesome again being at that stage once
you have three to five portfolio
projects is a really great um step to
take but yes now it's time to look for a
job so what types of jobs are not only
going to be inclusive of girly girls but
also celebrate them there are tons of
jobs in the beauty and fashion industry
that very much need tech and embrace
Tech and have apps for their digital
stores and digital experiences and
things like that and need those apps
built out and so who better than someone
who knows makeup very well to apply for
Sephora's developer program because they
need developers to make their tools of
trying on different makeup looks without
having the physical product
I want to put together a list of
different companies and jobs that fit
under this category of jobs in the
beauty industry fashion industry some
type of girly industry that a girly girl
would absolutely flourish in other
Industries include Industries in
something creative for example canva is
a fantastic software company that would
I'm pretty sure Embrace a girly girl
because they're all about Aesthetics all
about art and creativity and colors and
pop and glitter and all that and so I'm
going to provide not only Industries and
jobs within those Industries but also
specific companies and types of
companies that I think would embrace you
with open arms let me do a final path
through for my blush that I just added
because it is a liquid
blush my hands are
just o I'm so glad I wore a white shirt
but whatever but there there we go
everybody there we go girls that is my
video on just your guide to Tech while
still being 100%
1,00% you and embracing that all along
the way so I hope this was informative I
hope this was helpful and please let me
know in the comments what questions you
have for me and what you'd like to see
next thanks y'all I'll talk to you later
bye again my hands
bye